welcome to google cloud drawing board
where we doodle our way through the
cloud
today's topic what is dataflow this
video
is divided into chapters so watch the
full video or skip ahead to any section
of your choice
data is generated in real time from
websites mobile apps
iot devices and other workloads
capturing
processing and analyzing this data is a
priority for all businesses
but data from these systems is not often
in the format that's conducive for
analysis
or for effective use by downstream
systems
that's where dataflow comes in dataflow
is a serverless
fast and cost-effective service that
supports both streaming
and patch processing it provides
portability with processing jobs written
using
open source apache beam libraries and it
removes operational overhead from your
data engineering teams
by automating the infrastructure
provisioning and cluster management
how does dataflow work in general a data
processing pipeline
involves three steps you read the data
from a source
transform it and write the data back
into a sink
the data is read from the source into
something called
a p collection the p stands for parallel
because a p collection is designed to be
distributed across multiple machines
then it performs one or more operations
on the p collection
which are called transforms each time it
runs a transform
a new p collection is created that's
because p collections are immutable
after all of the transforms are executed
the pipeline writes the final p
collection
to an external sync once you've created
your pipeline using apache veeam sdk
in the language of your choice java or
python you can use
dataflow to deploy and execute that
pipeline which is called
a data flow job dataflow then assigns
the worker virtual machines
to execute the data processing you can
customize the shapes and size of these
machines
and if your traffic pattern is spiky
data flow auto scaling automatically
increases or decreases the number of
worker instances required
to run your job dataflow streaming
engine separates compute
from storage and moves parts of pipeline
execution
out of the worker vms and into the
dataflow service backend
this improves auto scaling and data
latency
now how do you use dataflow you can
create dataflow jobs using cloud console
ui
gcloud command line interface or the api
you have options while creating the job
you can use dataflow templates
write a sql statement or use ai platform
notebooks
dataflow templates offer a collection of
pre-built templates with an
option to create your own custom ones
you can then
easily share them with others in your
organization
dataflow sql lets you use your sql
skills to develop streaming pipelines
right from the bigquery web ui
you can join streaming data from pub sub
with files in cloud storage
or tables in bigquery write results into
bigquery and then
build real-time dashboards for
visualization
you can use ai platform notebooks from
the dataflow interface itself
to build and deploy data pipelines using
the latest
data science and machine learning
frameworks
data flow inline monitoring lets you
directly access
job metrics to help with troubleshooting
pipelines
at both the step and the worker level
how to secure data flow pipelines when
using dataflow
all the data is encrypted at rest and in
transit
to secure the data processing
environment you can turn off public ids
to restrict access to internal systems
leverage vpc service controls that help
you mitigate the risk of data
exfiltration
additionally you can create a pipeline
that's protected with customer managed
encryption keys
now what does it cost to use dataflow
dataflow service usage is built in per
second increments
on a per job basis depending on
streaming
or batch data for batch data processing
you can utilize the flexible resource
scheduling feature that reduces the cost
by using advanced scheduling techniques
each data flow job uses at least once
data flow worker
and the price depends on the worker
configurations
where to use data flow dataflow is a
great choice for any batch or streaming
data that needs
processing and enrichment for the
downstream systems such as analysis
machine learning or data warehousing
some examples are stream analytics
enabling real-time business insights
real-time ai enabling predictive
analytics fraud detection
personalization processing streams of
log data
unlocking health insights for your
systems and of course
any other data aggregation and analysis
scenario
want to learn more about dataflow check
out cloud.google.com
dataflow